翻訳: Mika Ikeda
校正: Shiho Nakamura
我が家は 安土桃山時代
天正３年
西暦で言うと1575年より
城端蒔絵という小原家独自の
漆による装飾技法を案出し
一子相伝で継承しております
今年（2016年）は 創業441年
代々 小原治五右衛門の名を襲名しており
私が16代目です
本日はその441年の
口伝で伝わる歴史から感じた
私の思いをお話しいたします
皆さんの 生まれ育った場所 環境
子供の頃から現在
普段 大切にしていること
家族 友人と
重ねて聞いて頂けましたら幸いです
我が家には
子供と大人の境界線がありません
ですから私はいつ
子どもから大人になったのか分かりません
私は幼い頃から
絵を描くことや
物を作ることが大好きでした
図工の課題で描いた絵が
私にとっては未完成でした
これで終わりではなく
自分が描いた絵を立体にしたい
でも授業はそこで終わりました
「先生 これからじゃないですか！」
と思いました
そんな私は現在 自分が描いた絵を
形にする仕事をしています
物づくりが好きだった私の姿を
家族は嬉しそうに見てくれていましたが
祖父にも 父にも
「この仕事を必ず継げ」と
強制されたことは 一度もありません
漆は埃を嫌う仕事です
仕事場にさえ
入れてもらえませんでした
「この道に進みたければ
自分で歩いてこい
人生の答えを買おうとするな」
祖父 父の背中から
こう聞こえてきました
祖父は私にこう言いました
「世界史 日本史の前に
城端史を学びなさい
小原家に生まれた人間として
これは知っておきなさい
生きていくうえで
大切なことが揃っている」
この言葉には説得力がありました
なぜなら
祖父の話の中に出てくるものが
ごく身近に存在していたからです
漆芸家である前に人間として
南砺市 城端に生まれ育った
城端人として生きること学びました
10才の頃には
祖父の言葉を信じて生きていこうと
決心しました
しかし おじいちゃんの言葉は
学校のテストにはまったく出ず
（笑）
私の小中高校時代の成績は
本当にひどいものでした
私は 城端の歴史や文化に
近いところで触れることができる
環境で育ちました
そしてこの地で生きた
多くの文化人たちの存在を知りました
歴代の治五右衛門も この城端で
漆芸だけではなく
絵画 彫刻 和歌 俳諧 医学 蘭学
天文学 暦象 測量など
様々なことを学び
友と研究に没頭したのです
文化が 友情によって生まれ
文化が 人と人とをつなげ
友情が生まれる
そこには 物を大切にする精神
助け合う心
土地に対する 信頼 感謝
これらの熱い心に人が集まり
町人文化が築き上げられたのだと
感じました
「命の循環」です
地方と聞くと
まるで中心から外れた場所のように
聞こえますが
江戸時代の城端人たちは
自分たちの住む城端が中心だという
意識で暮らしていたのだと思います
そして彼らは
気づいていたのだと思います
漆の生命は何千年
漆から見れば
今日生まれてきた赤ちゃんも
今100才のおじいさん おばあさんも
皆同世代だと
同じ時代を生きる結束力が100年
200年
300年前の
作品から伝わってくるんです
それは城端神明宮の
春季大祭で巡行する
曳山や庵屋台です
小原治五右衛門は
漆器をつくることだけが仕事ではなく
城端文化を築く中心の一人だったということに
私は感動し誇りに思いました
祖父は「膠漆（こうしつ）の交わり」
という言葉を教えてくれました
膠は「にかわ」
漆は「うるし」
どちらも固まると非常に硬い
そんな固い絆で結ばれた
人間と人間の関係を表す言葉です
７代 小原治五右衛門と荒木和助
７代目は曳山の意匠設計
そして髹漆（きゅうしつ）を手がけ
多くの門弟を育てました
和助も 彫刻師だけではなく
陶芸家で絵師でもありました
彼もその曳山の御神像を始めとする
人形彫刻を担当しました
この「膠漆（こうしつ）の交わり」
によって作られた
曳山や庵屋台に塗られているものも
膠と漆なんです
私はダヴィンチや
ミケランジェロを知った時に
外国にも治五右衛門や和助のような
人たちがいたんだと知りました
７代目以降 代々
私も先人からからこのバトンを預かり
曳山の制作修理に携わっております
「441年の伝統を背負えと言われ
重く恐ろしくないですか？」と
聞かれることもありますが
私は一度もそう思ったことはありません
もう一度言いますが
小原家には子どもと大人の
境界線がないからです
そして私は独りではありません
城端や 曳山の修復を通して出会った
親友たちがいます
住んでいる距離以上に
心と心の距離が近いのです
何百人の方々の前で話をするよりも
一人で作業している時の方が緊張します
城端や先祖に見られているからです
「伝統の家系に生まれ
反発はなかったのか？」
こう聞かれることもよくあります
ありました
しかしそれは
我が家に対してではなく
現代社会に対してのものでした
物が大量に作られて
平気で捨てられる
使い捨てるものが世の中に溢れ
どんどん均一化されていく時代に
「そうじゃなかっただろう？
俺たち城端人は」
「現代人の不安というものは
科学の発達からくるのでは？」
そうも考えました
「そんなこと言ってたら
生活にならないぞ」
「じゃあ生活って何だよ？
それが生きる活動なのか？」
我々の父祖が大切にしてきた暮らしに
侵略を感じたのです
これが中学生の頃です
田舎を恥ずかしいと
思うことが恥ずかしい
だって自分たちを育ててくれた
土地じゃないか
語学が堪能でも
本質を知り 自分の足元を語れないと
何にもならない
「世界へ 世界へ」と言いますが
パスポートを持って飛行機に乗れば
誰でも行けます
城端も世界です
ローカルを極めることこそが
グローバルであると
「『真行草』の『真』が抜けたものは
全て間抜けである」と
先祖の作品 下図 道具から
いろいろと聞こえてきます
伝統は 筋を伝えること
その筋の根幹にある命の尊さを
親から子へ
子から孫へと伝えてきたのです
これは 幸せが
人それぞれであるように
皆さんが持っているものだと思います
私は自分が何のために
命を授かり生まれてきて
何をしなければならないのかが
はっきりしております
命を授かり
心を授かり
技を授かり
宝を預っています
そして16代目の新たな１ページを加え
伝統を次代へつなげるという
責務があります
こういう 治五右衛門の意識
城端人の意識が
城端蒔絵 城端曳山祭りとして
何百年も継承されてきているのです
ここで皆さんに
ひとつお願いがあります
皆さんも
自分が何のために
命を授かり生まれてきて
何をしなければならないのかが
はっきりしていると思います
ぜひその筋を伝えていってください
そこには 命の循環が生まれます
お陰様 お互い様の精神が
美しいものを生み出していくのだと
歴史が証明しています
私たちの心の中には
祈りがあります
尊いものを尊いと感じたときに
必然的に生まれる祈りです
このTEDxも
いずれインターネットで
見ることができるでしょう
世界中のどこにいても
布団の中に入っていても
しかし 今日のこの会場の命は
ここにいる方々にしか
伝わらないと思います
そして私が今ここに立っているのは
当然 私だけの力ではなく
城端があり
歴代の治五右衛門がいて
その時代 その時代に友がいて
縁の下で支えてくれる家族がいて
TEDxHimi実行委員会の皆さま
そして
本日をお集まりの皆さまの支えがあり
今ここにこうやって
立たせて頂いております
私はこの命の尊さを
世界の人たちと共有していきたい
これは 世界へ向けての
発信であると同時に
近くにいる家族
そして
大切な大切な
わが子 孫へのメッセージです
これも小原家の口伝なのかもしれません
ありがとうございました
（拍手）